hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about micro rnas
what they are and how their expression
seems to be changing during aging
and age-related diseases and then we'll
use this information
to address whether or not micrornas
could ever be used as biomarkers for
aging
and be complementary to other methods of
assessing biological age
so the majority of the video will focus
on this recent nature communications
publication
common diseases alter the physiological
age-related blood micro rna profile
however at the end we'll also look at
this i suppose relatively recent
article that showed that nmn
supplementation promotes anti-aging
micro rna
expression profile in the aorta of aged
mice
and so this lasted paper relates a bit
more to the question about whether or
not micrornas could ever be predictive
of biological age
and help in the assessment of whether or
not anti-aging supplements
are effective so let's start with what
are micrornas
now i'm a bit of a biochemistry nerd and
i actually think
micrornas are fascinating and i know
that i'm not alone in my feelings
so what do they actually do then well
micrornas are somewhat suggested by
their name are rna molecules and they
act
in the post-transcriptional
downregulation of gene expression
now that may sound a bit complicated but
what it means is that micrornas
prevent the production of different
proteins by inhibiting
translation of different messenger rnas
and the way that this works is that
micrornas are single stranded
and they can have complementarity to
different messenger rnas
and through this interaction between
micrornas and messenger rnas
the micrornas can bring in different
machinery within a cell
that can either cause that messenger rna
to get degraded
or can repress the translation of that
messenger rna
now i had three awesome lectures on
micrornas
shout out to d skadon so if you don't
fully follow what i just said
i'm sorry micro rnas are quite
complicated
but the simplest way to think about it
is that micrornas
play a key role in regulating the
expression of many different genes
within a cell
and therefore they can influence many
different cellular and biological
processes
the shocking thing is because they're
not messenger rnas they're micrornas
they're often ignored
in transcriptamic studies that have
tried to understand the aging process
and rejuvenation of aged tissues and so
it's largely uncharacterized what really
happens to micrornas during aging
but you might be wondering do we really
care what happens to micrornas
during aging well i think that there are
two reasons why we should care
firstly by understanding what micrornas
are changing during the aging process
it might give us some insight into the
mechanisms that seem to be underpinning
the aging process and identify new
molecular targets
and then the second reason is that what
really is needed
in the aging field at the moment are
really reliable
biological aging clocks i.e methods that
can
determine the biological age of an
individual based on a series of
biomarkers
and this is useful for trying to assess
the efficacy
of different potential anti-aging
treatments
and there are several different clocks
that have been developed already that
i've covered in a previous video
and these include epigenetic clocks that
look at dna methylation marks
all the way to plasma proteomic
profiling that looks at different
proteins that are present within the
blood plasma
and the reason that these biomarkers are
needed is that aging is a dynamic
non-linear process so in many ways the
more biomarkers we have the better
so in this nature communication study
they analyzed
the micro rna profile and whole blood
samples from 1334 healthy individuals
in addition they looked at the micrornas
present in individuals with different
age-related diseases
they had 944 patients with parkinson's
disease
607 with heart diseases and 586 with
non-tumor lung diseases
517 with lung cancer and 405
with other diseases and in total the
number of patients they had
covered both sexes across the lifespan
of 30 to 90 years old
and now of the 2549 annotated micrornas
that they looked at
1568 of those micrornas were found
to correlate with aging now around 50
of those micrornas increased during
aging and around 50
decreased during aging however when the
authors looked at these different micro
rnas
to look at what processes they're
involved with
it was seen that the micrornas that are
increasing
during aging are involved in a much
greater number of processes
suggesting that the micrornas increasing
with age have a higher functional
relevance
but so far these are just linear
correlations with age
and as i mentioned earlier aging is
thought to be a dynamic
non-linear process and so next they
tried to see if any of these micrornas
had
non-linear changes during aging and they
found that 116
of the 1098 micrornas that altered with
age
had non-linear changes during aging now
the interesting thing with the data set
that they had in this study
is that they had data not only from
healthy individuals but also
from individuals with different diseases
i say what they found in this study
is that the association that we've just
seen between age and micro rna
expression
is partially lost in the different
diseases but if we look at this figure
here you can still see that the micro
rna profile
for people with these different diseases
still changes during aging
and i think it's actually quite clear
here but as demonstrated later on in the
study
because the micro rna profile changes
four different diseases during aging
it suggests that if micrornas were ever
going to be used as biomarkers
for different diseases then there should
be different biomarkers
for younger people as opposed to older
patients
and i think this is a really interesting
point that actually extends from just
micrornas
that in the future using these different
biomarkers whether it's micrornas
transcriptomics
proteomics or epigenetics looking at
different diseases
then future biomarker tests using these
different strategies
may not only be established for a
specific disease
but also for a specific age range of
patients with that disease
but what about using micrornas
specifically for a biological age
biomarker
well one of the interesting things they
did in the study was look at the
age-related micrornas
and what different genes they're
regulating and then correlate that to
known information about age-related
proteins
and so this serves as a somewhat
validation of the microrna
changes as being important in the aging
process but moreover a 2017 publication
also tried to look at age-associated
microrna expression changes
in human peripheral blood and they
developed a linear model
that they referred to as microrna age
that's used 80 of these micro rnas
and it correlated modestly with
predicted age from dna methylation and
mrna expression suggesting that microrna
age
may complement mrna and epigenetic age
prediction models
so given that this nature communication
study also identifies
non-linear changes within the micro rna
expression
there seems like there could be
potential of developing a potentially
more accurate micro rna age that could
either be used alone as a biological age
predictor
or as they say in this paper could be
used in combination with
other biomarkers and then this finally
brings us on to the last study that i'm
going to talk about today which is
nmn supplementation promotes anti-aging
microrna expression profile in the aorta
of aged mice
predicting epigenetic rejuvenation and
anti-arthrogenic effects
so the aorta is the main artery that
carries blood away from your heart
and according to this article there's
strong experimental evidence
showing that dysregulation of micrornas
has a role in vascular aging
moreover fascicular aging is
characterized by nad plus depletion
so what they were trying to do in this
study was to try and test both of these
hypotheses by treating mice with
nmn to see if it could alleviate the
changes seen
in the micro rna expression and well
what they found in this study is that it
could
but my main point of bringing this study
up was to kind of demonstrate that
micro rna expression could be used to
look at specific
tissues within the body as opposed to
being a systemic
biological age marker it could be let's
say a
biological age of your heart and i don't
know i've never really thought about it
but
maybe there could be different
biological ages for your different
organs
and so you could have let's say a
biological age
of 50 for your whole body but your heart
might be 60
your skin might be 45. that idea has
literally just come to my head
but it could actually be more
informative to have it for different
tissues
and then to use different supplements to
target different tissues
individually but i think i'm getting a
little bit distracted
but i think that's pretty cool anyway i
hope this video has
taught you about micrornas that i think
are super cool
and shown you that they do seem to be
changing with aging and that this
information could be exploited
both to further understand the
biochemical
underpinning of the aging process but
also to potentially
be aiding in the use of biological age
biomarkers
so as always i hope you've learned
something and thanks for listening